man flavor here and as usual I'm behind
the [ __ ] dumpster that's what I'm
working remember what I told you
[ __ ]
you can't put a silk hat on a pig
understand me that's why I do what I do
cause I'm a [ __ ] pig
but we're here smoking the bone of debt
in an alleyway somewhere in Denver
it's some tremendous reefer I got some
Opie dope or some [ __ ] Oh Jean I brought
this with me today I lay low I think
another weave stores tomorrow I make my
descent into the weave villages here in
Denver
and that's it I'm saying I always like
to check in with you [ __ ] you
know I love you to death I just want to
have another bowl of green chili no
parties for the cops and here we are
swinging dick [ __ ] smoking reefer the
[ __ ] Broncos are so the Broncos are
here and we still sold that that's what
the church is about that's why I love
you [ __ ] could you say [ __ ] the
Broncos uncle Joey's in town will coming
up gonna come down and party with a
party with the [ __ ] Broncos in
September season open I mean they're
[ __ ] out of town they're going down
I wouldn't [ __ ] even have a show
tonight he understand these people would
bury me that brung for [ __ ] fans I
don't [ __ ] blame I used to live out
here these Bronco people [ __ ] nuts
smoking this [ __ ] strong wheezing
high altitude does something to your
[ __ ] soul you understand me
I'm happy you guys clicked in I missed
you [ __ ] today
no podcasts no nothing
doing what we do best [ __ ] [ __ ] and
smoke a [ __ ] reason and don't get no
better than that my [ __ ] you know why
guys because you guys are the baddest
[ __ ] I know who asked us to do
this [ __ ] whoo whoo whoo
nobody us as a [ __ ] family that's who
the church as a [ __ ] family don't get
no better than this on my [ __ ] book
understanding oh I love it
I love when this roach gets it down here
this little [ __ ] power the [ __ ]
reason comes up my friend all these
Harvey homos in this [ __ ] restaurant
looking around and smoking reefer hope
it's gluten-free
the [ __ ] daddy I'm smoking 3x on this
[ __ ] the reefer I get this three
cold skull bones and the [ __ ]
skeleton head is pop [ __ ] open that's
the [ __ ] I'm gettin understand anyway no
edibles tonight I'm on SOPA
Chiba choose showing up tomorrow night
ooh I just gotta [ __ ] by the dumpster
ain't nobody gonna smell that smells
like [ __ ] anyway I got another joint of
my pocket of the [ __ ] banana oh gee
I'm the man of many joints I'm saying
I'm the man of many pipe he's the man of
many bugs and the man of many many many
many joint
[Music]
same time this is as good as it gets
this is it now you can go to bed in
peace uncle Joey got high with me I got
high with uncle Joey now you go to bed
you peace this is it
as we said good man life's [ __ ] pumpin
pumpin like a [ __ ] like a drunk bubble
bubble bubble do you think it's [ __ ]
Terry Bozzio playing the drums on my own
but that's it guys this is the best
thing about out there that we get the
sometimes we'll take that day together
little reefer together
and partake with a family because we
really are a family you might not [ __ ]
think so but we really are [ __ ] family
a family who smokes together stays
together you understand and that's
basically it
this [ __ ] roaches done
[Music]
they're still kicking like a [ __ ]
meal kick that [ __ ] meal [ __ ]
put a way to whip the horses dead when
they get too small you suck you swallow
the [ __ ] Road you burn your [ __ ]
pants and so you gotta be careful
nice all right we got another [ __ ]
bone left I'm gonna smoke it before
showtime I'm saying plenty for war
always if there's an earthquake already
full warp there's a tornado I'm ready
for war
if this [ __ ] if the devil comes down
from the [ __ ] sky I'm ready for war
and I suggest you do the same I love you
caucus up kiss with all my heart I'm
gonna do this [ __ ] show and I'll
touch base with you [ __ ] later
right stay black be strong and tell them
all to suck your dick